oh you to an incontinent I'm Schwab
social entrepreneur get divorce the
world economic forum and there's a big
economic issue I've been discussed here
which is really about the exclusion of
many girls for so many opportunities and
of course the likelihood on economic
downturns if that situation will elect
universe so we will undermine the real
opportunity exists change my work is in
Alfred level I lead an organization can
set the campaign to female education but
is supporting education leadership and
integration of girls are young I came to
Davos fire zambia in fact this time last
week I was in a village and they've
certainly not question regarding
international atomic crisis but they
will feel it as no doubt to like that
there was a report published by the
whole banking 2007 it showed that in the
time between 1980 international oh and
other economic downturns over a million
babies died which would otherwise have
fined and that's the reality it's a
crisis of immense proportions tell me
that but what will also happen is that
yours will needs more immature
apparently 600 million children tried
education 75% of them girls and if they
duly true age 10 11 12 but they will
marry young they will start having
babies when they're very young and their
babies are and will be born into poverty
and the whole intergenerational cycle of
poverty will start again and it will
resonate them years and that's that's an
issue for all of us natural issue for
the whole global economic community
because of course it affects everything
it affects population growth in
affecting the environment it affects
child health and child mortality so
there's a real opportunity to address
bits to recognize
the enormous impact that the prices will
have on the poorest of Nations we can on
the poorest in those nations to take a
look at this website open w george m /
to org and get involved in change and
support the opportunities are must be it
everyone